[Alkış]
[Müzik]
İnsanın kendisi yaptıklarını öbürüne
kasma kasnak etsin anlatmasıdır ama
mütevazı olduğu için
[Müzik]
bölge olarak şanslıydım
mesela tanımak istiyorum burada Merak
ettim Sayın abiyle Naim abi ile beraber
aynı bölge aynı kasabından iki farklı
köyündeydik
belki hep kötü kötü yerlerde
[Müzik]
olmaktan dolayı bugüne kadar iyisiyle
ırka kazandırımdan dolayı mutlu ederek
10 yaşına kadar Köyde her çocuk gibi
oyun peşinden koşarken
komşumuz İbrahim
[Müzik]
fakat şöyle bir cümle beni kesmek
lazımdılar dedi ki
kasabaya gideceksin yani
[Müzik]
Ama tek tek amacı okuyabilirdik ama
senin oraya gitmek istemiyoruz ancak
gidersen asla bu eve bir daha
getiremezsin
Ayrıca Hafta sonundan cumartesi günü ve
eşyalarımı yıkarız ve ertesi gün
kapılar sana kapalı dedi tabi
Babam dedi yaparlar ufak tefek ama
kırmızı kırmızı
almayacağını biliyordum öyle dedim
[Müzik]
fakat Bulgaristan'da 1985 yılından geçti
Bizim burada isimler değişmeye
başlayınca der ki bundan bitmedi
sanat ve spor
gençleri eğitim sistemi dışında
sadece eğitim vermeye başladılar
[Müzik]
akabinde
89 yılında sınırlar açıldı sınırları
açıldı işte durumu iyi olanlardı
[Müzik]
birçok kişi tiyatımıza ilk aşamada 300
dedim
vatandaşımız gelmişti Tabi biz
gelemeyenlerdendik Çünkü köyde hala
hayatımız devam ediyordu dedim ki
çok iyi olması lazım
tabii ki
o bizde yoktu cesaretle
[Müzik]
Gelemediler ve yatak odasında
sınırlar kapatın çünkü içerisinde fakat
bunlara beni yaldırsın bu güldürmek
istemiyordum hatırı yapmak istiyordum ve
farklı kulüplere gittim ama Ancak
dediğim gibi YouTube Bu otobüs için
Türkiye'ye gitmeyeceğini Söylememe
rağmen maalesef kabul etmekten beri
orada halkı yapamamak
Her şey bitti dedim okudum Dün gece bir
mektup geldi ve
Eyüp'te
falan genelde yerel gibi aile
alırsa yanında
Gelecek olan aileleri bize son fiyata
keşfet edebiliyor
Türkiye'ye gelmek için
izin almak
ihtimali yapamayacağım
tabi benim için kolay olan bir karardı
ama Anne babam için çok çok zor bir
karardı Sağ ol Allah razı olsun dediler
ve o zamanki yerleşiminde
dedim ki bir yerlere gelelim aileler
getirmem gerekiyor Türkiye'de öbür ayda
hakkımı köyden kasabaya götüremedik
İbrahim Hoca'dan yana kullandı ve o da
Burger size kalmıştı çünkü onun ailesine
verelim Türkiye'ye geldik
kendilerini Sakarya'ya gönderdik ve ben
oralı içerisinde tek başıma Ankara'ya
gitti ve Ankara'da
gelin bir ayet var
[Müzik]
Tabii ki başkaları ederken
tabi
bunlar çok önemli evde konular çok
önemli ama
[Müzik]
eğer her zaman da dediğim gibi hiçbir
zaman kendisi zirvede görmedim hep daha
fazla yapabileceğime inanarak hareket
ettim hayatta öyle hareket edeceğini
[Müzik]
1995 yılında
dünya şampiyonu
94.000'de daire Bilecik geri vardı Onlar
da diyeyim size tabii Türkiye'ye
geldikten sonraki
çıktığı ve o zaman
Rahime kıble ecelinden
çıkmıştı bundan sonra hani destanlar ne
de Türkiye'de genellikle gidebilecek
bunu örnekler olduğunu biliyordum Çünkü
YouTube 86 yılda Naime abimiz Türkiye
ticaretinde ki iltica yerlere doğru
bayağı böyle bu yasa tebrik ederek
aşırı Türkiye'ye geldik biz biraz daha
şanslı birisi hazır bir şekilde geldik
[Müzik]
başarabileceğine inanaraktan İnşallah
Habibi olursa bir gün o zaman belki bu
sınırları anne baba bu açılır diye bu
gayretim çalıştı ve
1994 yılında İstanbul'da
büyüklerde yaşıyordum artık
hani
6 kaldırıcılar bizde
internete bakarak dünyada tilki
gerçekleştirdi ve şahit olduk
[Müzik]
kesinlikle birinci olacağına veyahut da
Maalesef 2 gibi oldu
Ama buradaki sıkıntı
içinde yaşıyorsun ve yanılma esnasında
[Müzik]
tabi dünyada
gereklidir
kimseye çekerken rahmetli bacaklarımızda
tuttu Savaşı oldu
[Müzik]
fakat hiçbir zaman vazgeçmedim
ancak Oldu tabi bu hesapta zamanı vardır
ama belli bir şey Her şeyden önce
[Müzik]
rakiplerine 5 milyon
ve arkamda
sömürlerini kendi ekibinde teknik
ekibine
[Müzik]
daha fazla çalışmaya gayret ettik orada
kendileri çıkartmış oldum şimdi öğrendik
Efendim müsaade ederse tekrar bu
sizinle
96 yılında
şampiyon olduktan sonraki yaşlarda
hareket eden her zaman
[Müzik]
kabul ederdim ama maalesef bunu kabul
etmek zorunda kaldım Ama dediğim gibi bu
süreçleri şöyle bir şey acaba
kefir yaşandığı bir hayalim olması diye
hedefim olmasaydı ve
Hani dünyada bir iki geçici olmasaydı
Çünkü 2008 olup erken gitmiş olsaydı
ki normal şartlarda gitmiş olsaydım
zaten başarıyordu inanıyorum ama hiçbir
sürece kazanıp sayamazsınız bu da bir
gelecek en iyi bilenlerden biri
başıma gelmez diye düşünüyorum
ve her zaman biz
karşılık Beklerken maalesef
zararları veriyor
bu zararsızdı
[Müzik]
spor yapmak
iyi bir şey Ama belli bir tılsa zaten
bitiyor ki benim için de bitti
bizim oyuncular genellikle Siyasette çok
isterler
özellikle teklifie
aslında Çünkü herkesin ülkede kendi
işini yapması gerektiğini en onlardan
edemediğimiz
ama iyi bir gün için olurdu
bu zamana istemiştim
[Müzik]
çocuklarımıza bir şeyler katmaya
çalışacağım
[Müzik]
olmasa da kendi alanında
bizsiz dönemimizde en ileride biriydi ve
iki tane Almanlar iste uğraşırlar
sa
[Müzik]
tabi çok hoşuna gitti
itibarı vermesi ama
birisi olarak biraz da üstü
geliyor başından geliyorum
inşallah o
abisi gibi yarı yolda bırakmaz şimdi
Baba seçildiği zaman
kendimi anlatabilirim kendini ifade eden
Keyfim adını söylüyorum beceremedim
İşte rahatlatmaya çalıştım sizleri Şimdi
benim ne demek istediğimi
anlamışsınızdır dediğim gibi mücadeleyi
seviyorum
vazgeçmek hayatın hiçbir zaman olmadı
kim her zaman koyarım
kendimle alakalı bir karakterin
özelliklerini de söyleyeyim kendinle
alakalı bir şey varsa her zaman içinde
giderim
zamana bırakıyorum ama genel
anlamda karşılaşır
öyle bir bilgi sahibi Peki dışından
dolayı da şu anda beklediğim noktada
değilim ama dediğim gibi
[Müzik]
yapabileceğini inanıyorum ve Kim o borç
hissediyorum öğrenim sistemi
[Alkış]
[Müzik]
İyi ki de 10 yaş 16 yaşındayken
Bulgaristan'dan bırakıp da
Ama bu kadar başarılı olmuşum Çünkü de
bu bayrağın altına gerçekten çok
mutluyum Yoksa sizler tekrar tekrar
teşekkür ederim sağ olun